it's not for the weak girls if I'm
honest it was
hard I don't know if I'd recommend it
it's just a
[Music]
different feeling I don't know how to
explain it
like like it feels
intense like more intense than you
thought it
might
definitely
sorry just take
[Music]
yeah all right guys welcome back to LD
live um this topic that we're talking
about is a very sensitive topic if you
are a child and you are a minor please
pause the video and go find your parents
cuz uh we uh want to be sensitive to
that this is not for every
also this is a sensitive topic and why
are we talking about this we're not
discussing this to shed any light on
this issue we are talking about this
because it's not talked enough in the
church and there's so many people in the
church even pastors dealing with this
issue who are familiar with the platform
and if we go talk about it and point
back to Jesus who solves all these
problems then the problem says so this
this individual ual right here her name
is Lily and uh she's an only fans uh
model now I did not know that only fans
is not just adult content it's kind of
like a patreon um website where you know
people show up and it can also be you
can be a musician or some other content
creator and people can subscribe to you
or there's paperclick to review content
I'd feel weird to put a Ministry on
there
like follow us on only fans people might
get the wrong idea because of the
yeah yeah so so the reason why only fans
became so adult focused is because I
guess during Co people are looking more
for more ways to make money and only
fans the way to make money very quickly
and of course there's a huge audience
for adult
content and yeah so patreon is is open
to like some stuff like this but like
it's just it can't be any not that open
not that open at all and so only friends
is really the place people go to so Lily
um got into the news for like I a good
month right now about that she
apparently had sex with 100 men in one
day she wanted to try it out it wasn't
the record but she wanted to try it out
yeah and it's uh it's really sad how
disconnected she is from all of this
from the emotional spiritual side of of
of intimacy so Russell Brand uh who
recently became a Christian he actually
spoke to her about this this issue and
I'm not sharing Russell Brand videos
because we fully endorse Russell Brand
it was just a really interesting
interview and I actually really
appreciate some of the things he said to
her so let's take a look at the first
clip there's kind of no way that anybody
could be fulfilled like it's interesting
when i s of when I speak to I guess
certainly before everything got on top
for me um in the United Kingdom with
documentaries and attacks and stuff like
young men would say to me oh my God
what's it like what's it like what's it
like to be out to sleep with as many
women as you want to and I would sort of
say is it's kind of in some ways really
really amazing but it's amazing mostly
to know something that most people will
never know that you cannot be fulfilled
by the pursuit of carnal pleasure that
sex is not an object in itself but a
condiment a kind of an accompanyment to
love and also sex is the act of the
creator it's the Act of Creation
creating life I believe that sex is
pleasurable because it's the act by
which we create life it's when we are
perhaps most like God and to
misappropriate and misuse that power is
is transgressive and to use a sort of a
bit of an oldfashioned word sinful I I
wonder what you think about this Lily
for men just from a if if you didn't
believe in God from a biological
perspective men sleeping with lots of
women kind of Mak sense because a man
don't get pregnant a man's not going to
Bear the responsibility a man if he
wanted to could just leave and his genes
are passed on his jobs done for a woman
the AC of sex carries a potentially
quite High sort of price as well as a
potential for a great blessing of
pregnancy and I wonder how you feel
about how the active sex could ever be
anything else for you again this is not
an absolute argument because we all do
things when we're young that would not
be appropriate when we old full stop
what in particular with regard to your
attitude towards sex can you imagine sex
ever being s Sanctified again and an
expression of unique and special love
between you and someone that you want to
spend the rest of your life with um not
not in that way like I believe in having
multiple partners I don't believe in
monogamy that's the word um and so not
not really I I think sex can be special
but it it doesn't necessarily mean like
you have to just have sex with this one
person for the rest of your life and
make love and you know you're only
having sex to have children I I I really
wonder if I mean obviously it's her
brand so she's going to promote
something that is in line with what
she's thinking I don't know she'd be
dead honest with you right off the bat
with like yeah yeah I feel awful and it
makes me cry in fact I've seen I've seen
videos of this girl crying yeah she did
cry you had a c that yeah yeah I I think
the same thing I think you're right like
would she be hypocritical if came out
and yeah said the other yeah you're
right no I'm not fulfilled during this
and and yeah I would hope that I would
make it special someday cuz it's not
really special right now I I have a hard
time believing that she's going to say
that right off the bat but I think if
you were honest I mean it's just human
biology like like they're not wired to
do
that it's sad yeah and I I I did a
little reading on this story I didn't
want to read too much but she talks
about some of those encounters and it's
like
they're not really spending that much
time together it was just like you know
you there wouldn't be
anything I guess desirable or special
about it I mean it's just like all
focused on some record and it's like
well what's it's empty so we interviewed
that guy that was like Ron Jery's um
producer remember him John John and um I
remember him telling me that the first
porn that he actually worked on he went
outside and threw up yeah like he was
like this is disgusting and I should not
be watching this and and you know it was
this this sort of like evil feeling that
he felt and then from there I've seen
interviews with some of the male guys
that have turned around and become
Christian and stuff like that and they
describe the like the Suicidal Thoughts
that they would have and I mean these
are guys that you would think would have
no connection to this whatsoever You'
expect a girl to act like that but a guy
like you wouldn't think he'd be
remorseful at all and that's not the
case Joshua Brun he's a he's one of the
more well-known converts so to speak uh
yeah he was suicidal as well yeah and
then he be he you know God saved his
life he actually met a girl who became
his wife and now he's a pastor with kids
and he's like I couldn't live a better
life think at the end of the day you
know we're all
chasing something better for lack of a
better term and and and we Chase it in
different
ways and so many people come to realize
at the end of the road there is nothing
else like it doesn't get better just
like people who you know they get high
and that first time it's it's really
great and they keep chasing that same
experience and they never get it so they
move on to another drug or another drug
or another drug this is the same kind of
thing and it just it's never satisfying
mhm and I think that only comes with
Christ we're just we're built that way
and so if you try anything else it's not
going to work porn is wrong and if you
kind of had a daughter you have a
daughter I do and if that was your
daughter saying these kind of things how
would that make you feel it' break my
heart it absolutely break your heart and
and and I think most normal people like
like when and when I mean normal is like
like people that grew up in a you know a
loving environment I understand if
you're abused you're going going to VI
this totally different but but in a
loving environment what is sexual it at
its core if you if you just distill it
down it is a relation based
activity and when you remove the
relation based activity out of that
equation then it's like nobody cares for
you who doesn't like to be cared for
yeah yeah it's not the end all be all in
the relationship it's it's uh a an
activity that bonds you together for
sure but it's not the end all be and so
if it's you know it's if it's built on
that yeah it's built on that it's going
to fall apart because it's not the only
thing holding you together right but but
in a a ultimate expression of love with
each other God gave us this beautiful
gift that was supposed to be shared to
bring to people really close together
that's why it's like outside of the
bounds of marriage is not what God
wanted for any of us because he's saying
I want this special thing that's going
to bring you together you got all these
challenges in life and this will glue
you together and when you cheat the
system even if you're just a passive
viewer of pornography you're cheating
the system and plus add on the top of
that the complexity if she ever does
realize how many people's lives she's
influencing and potentially ruining M
yeah well also because there's another
girl called Bonnie Blue that's her
friend it's like another porn star in ol
fans they work together a lot and um
yeah she even said I can do it better
than your wife like they just know what
their Jey they know they get husbands in
there it's ruining their lives and yeah
it's it's a really sad State of Affairs
I'm I'm actually saddened when you see a
girl like this and it's just like oh
just somebody tell her that you love her
you know like I don't think that these
men that are showing up for a one minute
L her no no they don't and that's the
other thing like intimacy is something
that um is God designed it to be
something in give you serve your stops
it's not about I'm going to get in there
and I'm going to get the job done and I
couldn't care less you're an object so
that's really what you going to start
seeing some of that if you if you
actually listen to interviews of girls
that have been in the porn industry they
didn't even like men they didn't even
you know it's not enjoyable to them this
activity and it's like they can say they
want to all they want to but it's acting
they're they're acting yeah you know if
they're going down this road of like I
can do it better than your wife I think
it's
probably appealing to a subsection of
the population that their relationship
is broken and so like they go to this
woman and it's like she seems like she's
into him you know guys they they want
their they want reciprocal you know like
they want their wife to be into them
they want that's just normal you know
and if you're in that broken
relationship and you find somebody's
like you know I can I can rock your
world or whatever that's going to be
appealing on a biological level but at
the end of the day better like it's it's
not the mechanics work the same no
matter who it is if you read the Bible
verse that says you know like her feet
are in in like hell but she's like
drawing you in with her lips or whatever
like that I can't remember the exact
verbage of it but um if you if if you
really honestly believe like this person
right here is going to bring me to lose
my salvation would you think
twice yeah I would hope so yeah and and
for her you know one day down the road I
don't know how long it's going to take
but what kind of regret is she going to
have well I I I praise God that Russell
Brown was bold enough to say what he
said to her yeah well he said a few more
things so let's take a look there's two
things I'm really interested in one is
the impact
of of of sex and sex for money and sex
as performance on your soul you Lily
Phillips on your precious soul and your
spirit and also all of us as human
beings like me everyone like what it
does to us if we start to use sex as a
kind of currency but one thing I wanted
to bring to you is like um my wife
actually was talking about someone she
knew where there was an exercise or
fitness instructor who was also an only
fans when I heard that this is what I
felt mate I was like whoa like that
means like I'm thinking about myself
when I'm 17 like if it would been
possible that you could sort of see a
mom at a school or a teacher or anyone
actually and then somewhere else you
could go and pay money and see that
person take their clothes off and
perform the most inim of things I don't
know what would have happened to me
psychologically that's just so
overwhelming and so ridiculous and so
exciting but also it's reducing
everybody to a kind of object yeah for
sure I agree which I think this goes
back to the topic of love if you're
really searching for the real definition
of love you know the Vampire movie is is
often using the element of love but is
it really love if they're willing to
suck your blood and take your life right
that's not really love that's called
lust and lust is I'm going to take
something from you and in this type of
situation love is a reciprocal two-way
street right and that doesn't mean like
you give me money and I'll do whatever I
like you want right that's not that's
not the definition of love that's not
reciprocating and so this by definition
I think is a very selfish thing to do
it's all about you the gratification of
the person that's watching them and then
also for her she didn't care about you
she didn't care about if your marriage
got ruined if your wife cries every day
because you're sitting there fantasizing
about other women she doesn't care about
that she cares about how much money am I
going to make right it's a selfish act
yeah I I saw his video of that and I
decided not to include in the show but
that didn't seem any good reason to do
that but I saw this clip where she was
on Tik Tok and and she was like yeah so
everybody this is so so and he won the
giveaway and he's going to come into the
bedroom with me and it's just like my
random dude who's like yo what's up and
he's like she's like oh and keep brought
ke brought his Ms and she's like hi um
but she's going to stay right here and
we're going to go to the bedroom now and
I'm like what like he's married no oh
my and I just I was just I literally sat
there for 30 seconds just not knowing
what to say I mean that's I mean
obviously it's a hug R's flag but you
know that relationship is not going to
be the same no it's not going to last
just imagine knowing like like it's
already bad enough when you're a wife or
a girlfriend and you know your partner
or spouse is cheating on you but let
alone that they just walk off in front
of you and go into the room and come out
and he looks all like we just had the
the ride of his life you know with her
if what yeah it's sad it's really sad
what you're saying right like this kind
of stuff breaks relationships and that's
the reason why I want to talk about this
topic because it's not just like oh
because some people might be watching
this and say well I'm not going there
just to sleep with her I'm just watching
her or anybody yeah but but the Bible
says that if you lust after a woman it's
like committing adultery it's the same
thing
yeah he just put a price on his
girlfriend pretty much I mean
essentially he just put a price on the
relationship and said it's it's worth
this much it's less valuable than what
yeah it's less valuable than than what
I'm about to go to for you know a minute
or two minutes or whatever it is that's
why I always thought it was sad when
when when like you hear how much a
celebrity is worth right and they say oh
this person's worth $20 million or
whatever like that and they'll do
whatever for $20
million that's sad you're
infinitely valuable M and it's like even
$20 million yeah that sounds a lot to
you but infin is way more than 20
million yeah you know have you guys ever
see this John 360 movie with train or
something it's pretty old you guys never
seen it a short it was a short film and
it was basically about this dad who I'm
just paraphrasing her um he was like a
train conductor or he worked on the
train tracks and there was a train
coming and his son was near the train
tracks and he has to make a decision am
I saving everybody on the train or am I
saving my son oh yeah heard the story
yeah and he made the decision to
sacrifice his son for the sake of the
people on the train but that's what God
did and that shows you the value that he
places upon each every one of us yeah
it's a really good documentary we saw it
I'm trying to think of the title of it
um the father and the son and he's they
play violin together and do you remember
maybe you didn't see it I know I saw it
um anyway father plays a violin son
plays a violin and then the son gets
enticed to go after this this woman he
keeps seeing beautiful woman so he
leaves the father and goes after the
woman all the way into like gets in this
lake with her right and go into the
water and she comes out and it's this
terrible dead skeleton right and he's
taken off and held captive and a
cave and he just remains there
chained violin gets busted broken all
that until the father goes to seek him
out find him unchain him bring him back
and he had been building another violin
for him to play again but it just shows
like he was chasing after this thing
which was just death was his heart of
man the heart of man that's what it was
he just didn't recognize it but it was
death it looks nice I need to watch that
I've seen clips of it and I've never
seen the whole thing but powerful
powerful documentary oh yeah it's it's
very good so and and obviously it's a
it's a metaphor right it's an allegory
for this whole thing of you know whether
it be pornography or sexual intimacy or
you know what have you it it kind of
hits everything in that realm if you
think about it um but yeah very powerful
lesson very well
done well let's see what she uh what her
reaction was after she actually slept
with 100 men when you know yeah yeah
have you even processed do you think
what's
happened not
yet I won't forget the
stage when I decided to start making
this documentary I wasn't too sure of
what to expect I certainly didn't expect
to see Lily so upset at the end of it
all I thought perhaps in years to come
she may look back at this day in sadness
but not so instantly afterwards she had
stressed to me throughout my time with
her how excited she was for this
Challenge and how this was her fantasy
so to see her so visibly upset at the
end of it all was really
sad but my confusion was only added to
in the days following our filming with
Lily as she announced to her fans that
in February of
2025 she would be sleeping with 1,000
men in a single day to break the world
record last week I did 101 guys now this
was just the warm up because in February
I'm going to be the first person ever to
reach four digits of guys all in one day
yes 1,000 guys maybe what we witnessed
that night was just someone overwhelmed
with emotion after completing such a
Monumental challenge or maybe we saw the
true toll this career can have on a
person okay so did she end up doing it
her co-star Bonnie Blue actually broke
her the record and did before Lily did
she slipped with what with 1,000 men in
12 hours 23 years old
from, 157
men I'm saddened yeah I can't imagine
that her reaction would be she was any
different no it wasn't actually she was
like yeah I'm fine I'm feeling great and
I'm
like I I don't understand you know I I I
imagine that it's a lot like kind of
doing drugs
you become so numb to the effect of that
um you know the first few times that you
do anything that you know you shouldn't
be doing you're you're going to feel
remorse for it but the more that you
kind of venture onto that ground you
become
soulless and I mean think about once
again I'm going to bring it back to to
the other people the Thousand guys who
that hopefully maybe somay they'd be
married and their wives are like you did
what with with some
girl yeah it's like it's like yeah your
parents can you imagine you're a parent
your mom your dad doing anything like
that like I I can't even imagine and and
what did she get out of it you know it's
like did they give her anything yeah I I
saw a video with um Russell Brand which
was very interesting I think it was
Russell Brand maybe it was uh Rous I
can't remember but um they were like
well how much money but it are you doing
this for money like is there an amount
of money that you're trying to do and
and and she was like no I don't know if
you've seen that clip either but it was
like it it was like they were basically
going look if I offered you this type of
money to go and make marriage counseling
videos would
you and it was like no I still would do
this and it's
sadh I'm I'm thinking of there's this
girl in the UK um years ago I came
across her testimony I think I think she
had some kind of a background like this
she was sharing this this visual this
image this this idea of imagine that
you're in a
house and these men they knock the door
open they come in with their muddy boots
you just mud everywhere right your your
fire goes out in your fire pit they eat
up all the bread and they leap and they
do this over and over and over again
you're cold you have no bread no fire
and all of a sudden there's a knock on
the door nobody ever knocks and you open
the door and there's Jesus and he comes
in he's like can I come come here and he
start mopping your floor with his own
blood cleans everything up lights the
fire again and fills the bread and sits
with you and just come hits you and
she's like that was my experience with
Jesus and she said the other one was my
experience with men and I was like Wow
and but that's what God offers both
women and men right like men who watch
pornography like for me to do research I
felt depressed just to like look into
this I'm going to keep looking at this
stuff like I wasn't doing you know
research like actually watching the only
fan stuff I was just Googling like
what's going on and all that kind of
stuff I just felt depressed and I'm like
I just looking up articles about these
people let alone if you're actually
watching this stuff or participating in
this stuff it's just not how God
designed us and it's designed by the
enemy to destroy everything God has made
good and let me put it this way too when
you watch it you support it if there's
no audience for it you don't you don't
put your stamp of support on it so I
know it's difficult I know it's
challenging I'm sure every single person
at least has been confronted with at
some point in their life it used to be
just a men problem now it's quite very
heavily a women problem and and it's
like we we we have to get a handle on
this and stop supporting this this is
ruining people's lives yeah I agree well
let's see how Russell BR wrap it up with
Lily in his interview I reckon what it
is ly say like when you become aware of
someone in the environment you get an
initial impression of them and if
someone's doing something as striking as
you're doing it's difficult for for me I
feel like a sense I want to reach out to
you a little bit because I suppose when
I was younger and when I before I was
married and before I had children I
suppose if I had heard of you I would
have been happy to see you as an object
and not to investigate that any further
but as a adult man and as a man of God
how I see you is is a fellow child of
God and part of me feels like I wonder
if there is any way that I can offer you
some protection or service or counsel I
would hope that anybody would have this
reaction and I think if you began to
look at every single one of these people
as not an object as an actual sad thing
have you have you ever seen the videos
um this video was so powerful they had
interviewed an adult star she was
talking about you know what it was like
and this and that and stuff and then the
interviewer said how would you like
people to see
you and she just like broke down and she
just started crying and she said I want
want people to see me as a as a mother
of three children that all I want to do
is provide for my family and this and
that and it's like that's what she
wanted people to see her as and no none
of these people in this business saw her
as that yeah and it was just like oh man
you can see like this person just wants
to be loved and so I think it's awesome
that Russell Brand was was offering this
to her I like the fact that he offered
to you you know he wanted to protect her
and you know he's coming at this later
in life and probably old enough to be
your father and and that kind of thing
but it should be in AI response no
matter what age but to say let me Shield
you from this because he recognizes like
this is doing you harm it's damaging you
I want to protect you from it you don't
see it in your early 20s but you'll see
it when you're my age and married and
wish that you hadn't had these
experiences yeah mhm sad I really like
what she said how do you want to be seen
as
and I think that's the takeway from this
video like if you want to be seen as a
child of God R to go you know but if you
ask yourself what is the reason that I
either watching porn or I'm involved
with it or I'm acting it what's the Reas
we dig really deep I think most people
just want to be loved like you said and
you know what's really amazing is
probably her him offering that even
though she didn't take his his offer at
this moment I guarantee you if everybody
else objectifies her and she never hears
that she's valuable or that she needs to
be protected or anything like that that
sentence right there is going to stick
with her you you wonder yeah you just
wonder like if somebody came in and was
like I want to protect you how much to
get you to stop doing this and they
offered her just like a a check like
just name your amount that would be
beautiful you know it would it would be
pretty awesome like here I'm going to
I'm going to help you I'm going to save
you I mean you're doing this for money
so what's it going to take we'll just
take care of it and you can be done I
wish I was a billionaire I mean would it
be awesome if you could do that with
people that's a brilliant idea you know
to to speak to the other though that
you're getting that you know I think
people they just get caught you think
about things that you've done in your
past and you get caught and you don't
know how to get out you don't know how
to escape you don't know what to do and
so you just you keep doing it
and people don't you know like you said
they don't run to Christ we we have that
same reaction every human being has that
same reaction as in the garden of Aiden
they're running away and God's the one
running after us and if we turned around
we' bump into himh because he's right
there and so you know I don't think we
can come here and say well I have all
the answers no I don't have all the
answers but I know the one who does have
the answers and that's Jesus and if you
have a struggle with this you know if
you have a struggle with
anything just go to Jesus you know you
can pour your heart out to him and he
can heal you he can deliver you he can
change you he can do it for
anybody and I think that's that's the
solution so can you imagine if Jesus
showed up to her like the woman at the
well and was like go get your husband I
don't have a husband I just did a
thousand guys yeah and he's like and
Jesus were to to go out of his way meet
her in Vegas or wherever she
lives that's what he's willing to
do yeah and the Bible talks about that
God wants to cover our nakedness with
his righteousness we are never too far
gone for about you want to do that we're
never too sinful and we would might be
end up in the gutter he's like I got you
will you will you open the door you be
say yes he cleans it all up with his
blood covers Us with his righteousness
and just sits down he Comforts us y
that's what the Jesus that's Jesus that
Ser yeah if you like this video like
comment subscribe and hit the
notification Bell so you know when we
launch new videos and drop a comments
below and we'll try to get back to you
if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say